because you guys live together in a sari
I apologize originally I met in the 6th
green the best friends ever since
it's just horrible um this guy right
here is my brother and then I moved to
Atlanta after high school
these three in college yeah when I first
thing you know when he came up I was
like why is he here so they had me
already so I was like it's no needful
how did he look I was very light-skinned
nose like a shriveled up reasons nothin
fever you know my room I was walking
past my apartment he was sitting on the
couch he said oh would you ain't gonna
speak it at that moment I knew I could
get him to do anything when we first
started we definitely said it we wanted
to do something you know something and
we definitely wanted to try to do
something
so but like hey you know we know about
Facebook's in the world the college
humors you know I mean all these
businesses that started from college do
something you know play off that so we
came with that idea for dorm sweepstakes
and how that would work
it was supposed to be like animation of
entertainment but I can't even save the
day he says everybody hated the worst I
think we're like you know what if we got
matching tattoos don't mean that we all
have to like guys no no no you can't
have a matching tattoo five okay guys
you're branded if you get branded you
and I do think that even though you know
we are comedians this is a comedy group
that you know we have two music
producers and all of us do music all
those write music
you know we are we do comedy but we want
to also expand outside of comedy you
know I think everything will do kind of
have a comedic Sensibility about it but
we definitely wanna be able to write you
know drama or
you know yeah yeah haters as opposed to
you know oh that's the comedy guy make
me laugh you know like Oh cuz it's a
little bit more respect when you can do
switch roles with certain days so
that'll grow when we come out and do
more things out of here there I think it
makes it work well because you know a
lot of groups you see especially in
music they're put together and that's
why I usually break up we we came to
organically so it was like we had a
friendship before business so that's
never gonna break before isn't true
we'll have arguments of course but we
get over there within minutes it's a
strong knit group this will be no egos
in this well we definitely have
different opinions on things but it kind
of just helps out if anything you know
because we get to see different
perspectives you know it was just for
what we want to do with our YouTube and
expand outside of YouTube we do need to
be here you know because we're we're
looking to not just live on where even
if you look at our skits and stuff do
you know they're eight minutes long nine
minutes long YouTube is 30 second cat
videos you know so we want to expand to
be we're not really youtubers you know
so we only expand outside of necessarily
just living
and that's this is a good place to be
for that I feel first we want to just
like a stated you know we don't set
ourselves for youtubers we're not saying
anything bad about people you know set
themselves youtubers but for us we
always want to own TV show we always
want to direct produce right so for us
Ellie is what we need to be for some
other people depending on what their end
goal was or if you know it doesn't
matter where they like Emmanuel is
saying because there are people who I
mean are twice as big as us we just do a
video in their room you know and just
talk to the camera and their end goal
was definitely was different right than
ours you know just different types of
things for different we went in front of
movie theaters she was hit with a gun
and I had to go yeah it was a fake it
was different but I mean it was like a
big robot now you know 99% of fans are
female and so
his fans are the milk Nokia Georgia my
fans are female so I feel like it's kind
of hard now to trust you know some girls
because you don't know if they genuinely
like you for you or is it just because
don't Amy and where we're going and it's
also like especially with YouTube even
people would just do vlogs to stuff you
you love your personality and you know I
mean it and sometimes they wanna date
the person is seen the video and not
necessarily you cuz you're still playing
a character even though you're being
yourself so it does because cam told me
the funniest thing the other day I said
I was with my girl
and you know we were taking a walk
somewhere and this guy was walking I'm
he was jogging now she would have shirt
off slow guy you know pretty boy
whatever that's not I was going through
the gym so he's coming down and I see my
look look it's fine go ahead he has a
shirt off mine alright and what it can't
so he's it that's whether she ain't got
more subscribers
Albarn Virginia Tech Pace University
City College of New York in the
University of Louisville well some of it
is hosting and then some of it is our
full shows that you do which has live
acts crazy can I touch you like yes
sometimes boxers on yes yo but you got
it down but it's like a true variety
show music comedy music we still show
skits on the screen so we wrapped up
shooting a Tracey Edmonds project
cooking show we produce a bunch of
gourmet budget that's dropping when a
june german our daily skits we still
work with our weekly skits right now
we're working on two scripts for a
feature film as well as TV show pretty
much gonna stop yeah I think eventually
you know everybody's gonna have their
little thing that they end up doing or
whatever but dorm team that's gonna get
us don't Ames not only don't ain't gonna
get us there but dorm thing is gonna
it's still a business we're not just you
know YouTube we are business so we're
still gonna have this business and we're
going to grow it to where it can exist
and do other things
no matter how old we get or how how much
kids we have or how mean you can run our
own business our there's a dock business
together our names are all on this this
this business and we're always going to
be come back to this and do something
forward in whatever it's so it's not
it's not like the Backstreet Boys on
this is a business you know we have to
use tickets every Sunday we're out here
working hard for you guys entertainment
if you don't know about us check out our
youtube check out our website their
skits for every one you do different
varieties of comedy we're just out there
trying to make the best on your
situation I didn't want to say trying to
check out our album broken flame mrs.
charted number one in comedy iTunes go
check it out